- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Priya Natarajan, an
astrophysicists and faculty
in the Department of
Astronomy and Physics at Yale.
I also serve as the current director
of the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities,
the Flagship Interdisciplinary
Program at Yale
that catalyzes intellectual exchange
and collaboration across
academic disciplines.
I am delighted to invite you
all to the monthly convening
of our Nature of Inference
Colloquium series.
First, I would like to
start by recognizing
the generosity of Mr and Mrs.
Richard and Barbara Franke,
whose support of this program
and many others at Yale
have vastly enriched
intellectual engagement
and innovative scholarship.
Then I would like to remind you all
that as we are recording this event,
that all participant
videos and microphones
will remain muted.
Please go ahead and submit
any questions you might have
through the Q&A feature.
Dr. Ty Kamp and I will be managing the Q&A
at the end of today's talk.
So I'm delighted to
welcome today's speaker,
partly because he's one of our own,
a distinguished member of our own faculty,
Dr. Nisheeth Vishnoi.
And before I tell you
more about his, you know,
various honors, accomplishments and so on,
I have to add that one of
the particular pleasures
of having one's own colleague speak
is when you have someone like Nisheeth
who is so incredibly
intellectually curious
that it is going to be an utter treat,
I promise you all, to
hear him speak today.
So as you all know, in
this wonderful series,
we've been exploring
how we know what we know
in terms of generating new knowledge
in a range of disciplines
that study varied phenomenon;
be it protein folding and structure,
and its implications and impact
on how our body functions,
or how we build models of
complex physical systems
like climate and make predictions.
Today's speaker, Dr. Nisheeth Vishnoi
is going to talk to us
about perhaps one of
the most complex systems
that we encounter;
how we individually and collectively
make sense of the world,
the ways in which we model
the world in order to do so,
and the limits of therefore what we know,
delving more deeply into
the profound questions
of where many of these
limits of what we can know
and what we do know arise from.
It is a real pleasure
to have one of our own faculty members,
a distinguished member of our faculty
Dr. Vishnoi talk to us today
about bias in algorithms.
So to give you a sense of
the breadth of interests
and the range of wonderful
original scholarship,
that Nisheeth has been engaging in,
let me tell you a little
bit more about him.
So he is the Bartlett Giamatti
professor of computer science
and the co-founder
of the Computation and
Society Initiative at Yale.
He studies the foundation of computation
and his research spans multiple areas
in theoretical computer science,
optimization, and machine learning.
He's also interested in
understanding the nature and society
from a computational point of view.
His current focus
includes studying entropy,
the range is gonna be astounding,
the emergence of intelligence
behavior, and ethical problems
at the interface of artificial
intelligence and society.
He has many, many honors and
I have cherry picked a few
so that I don't keep you
from listening to him
for much longer.
He was the recipient
of the Best Paper Award
at the IEEE symposium
on Foundations of
Computer Science in 2005,
the IBM Research Pat Goldberg
Memorial Award in 2006,
the Indian National Science
Academy Young Scientist Award
in 2011,
and the IIT Bombay Young
Alumni Achievers Award in 2016,
and, you know, multiple best paper awards
at various conferences.
The one that is relevant to our talk today
is at the ACM Conference on
Fairness, Accountability,
and Transparency in 2019.
He was named at ACM fellow in 2019,
and his most recent book,
"Algorithms for Convex Optimization"
was published by Cambridge
University Press.
And as is customary with
this colloquium series,
it will be followed with a conversation
with another distinguished practitioner
who brings a slightly
different perspective.
So following professor
Vishnoi's talk today,
we will have the conversation on Monday
with Professor Aleksander Mądry,
who will lead the postdoc
discussion on Monday evening.
So without further ado,
let me turn the floor over to Nisheeth.
Nisheeth, we are delighted you're here
and really looking forward to hearing you.
- Thank you, Priya for that
very generous introduction
and thank you all for being here.
Good afternoon, good evening
wherever you might be.
So if it's okay, I'm gonna
share my screen, Priya.
- Yeah, please go ahead.
- So the topic of the talk
today is bias in algorithms
and my plan is to give the listeners
a sense of how in this very
objective world of algorithms,
which live in this very
precise mathematical framework,
human-like qualities like bias can emerge,
and what can we do to intervene
and mitigate these algorithmic biases,
and in the process of trying to figure out
the ways in which we can
mitigate these biases
in the world of algorithms,
you will also see at the end,
how we can gain some insights
about mitigating bias
in the world of humans itself.
So let me start by
setting up the framework
the world in which we live in.
So it's not news to anybody here
that humans live in an algorithmic world.
Let me make this a
little bit more precise.
Us as a society are consuming
a huge amount of information
through various online channels
unlike, you know, a few years ago
where we were looking
at newspapers and so on.
Now everybody gets their news
through Twitter, Facebook,
or equivalent.
We connect with people through
these social applications,
which are made possible
through this worldwide web
or internet.
We are also increasingly using algorithms
in the context of
governance, policy and so on.
And last but not the least,
many of the utilities
that we consume today
from ride sharing apps
to online shopping
platforms are all governed
by decision-making algorithms,
which are constantly learning
about human preferences
through the data that they generate,
and presenting information
often in a personalized manner
to these individuals.
And this information is affecting
who we are as individuals
and giving shape to the
society in a very different way
and at a very different scale
than we imagined previously.
So this is the context that
I'm going to be talking about.
And let me say a few
words about algorithms.
And I'm gonna focus on
artificial algorithms,
which largely developed, you know,
the formal study of algorithms
and the discipline of
computer science is about,
you know, I would say a bit
less than a hundred years old
start with the works of Turing and others
who started looking at algorithms
or formalizing the notion of algorithm.
And in the last few decades,
we have come a very long way
in designing artificial algorithms,
which have shown the ability to mimic
some of the most complex
natural algorithms.
For instance, Priya had
mentioned protein folding.
I mean, one of the most recent successes
of artificial algorithms
is the ability to predict
the tertiary structure of proteins,
which has been one of the main challenges.
I have to mention beating the best players
in the most complex games,
predicting weather, you know,
and I guess the more relevant algorithms
that we are going to talk
about a little bit today
are things like, you know,
algorithms use in courts
and my judges which decide,
you know, who gets bail
and who doesn't get bail,
or artificial algorithms,
which are deciding who gets loan
and who doesn't get loan and so on.
So there is a vast and complex
landscape of algorithms.
Very, very, roughly you can think about
an artificial algorithm in today's world
as something which has a few components,
not necessarily all of them,
but there may be some data available
from which the algorithm
might want to learn.
To learn something, we
need to have a model,
we need to figure out,
you know, what is allowed
for us to learn.
I mean, when we trying to learn from data,
what are we allowed to use
in that learning process?
And that's the step that I'm calling
the statistical or reasoning model.
And finally, once you
have decided on the model
and you have the data, you
will need an algorithm,
which can then find the
best model from this data.
And we gonna talk a little
bit more about in detail.
So this is just a very high level view
for you to get a sense
of what many of these
algorithms look like.
And the point that I would
like to highlight is that
these decisions that we see here,
right from data to selection of models,
selection of training algorithm,
the selection of anything involves humans.
And so this is why we call it,
I mean, artificial
intelligence algorithms,
because, you know, humans
are making these decisions.
One thing that remains common
no matter which artificial
algorithm you look at
is that they live in a very precise world,
which is governed by
unambiguous mathematical rules.
And, you know, somehow people in society
associates objectivity to mathematics.
And we can go into that
at some other point,
but there is some association of objective
to the mathematical precision.
And so there was some
expectation from these algorithms
that they should also be objective
and not show human-like qualities.
Unfortunately, this is not true
and I guess this is not
news to anybody here.
Nevertheless, I will still
go through some examples.
I would say about less than a decade ago
many researchers started
auditing algorithms,
which are being used in
very, very broad settings.
For instance, search.
So you go on something like Google
and search for Google images
and search for something like a CEO.
And, you know, it's not like Google
just has these 15 images of CEO.
They got billions of images
probably which are not CEO.
And then based on what
it understands of you
and the word CEO,
it'll pull out a small subset
of images for you to see.
I mean, why small?
Because your screen is small,
your attention is small.
So you can't really
process billion images,
and perhaps that's not
what you're looking for.
So this process requires
solving an algorithmic problem
of selecting a subset for a
particular individual to view.
And presumably there are some objectives.
I mean, you know, the search is for free.
So there is clearly some
objective of showing
these images to you.
And one reasonable objective
that many of these companies
have is maximize engagement.
So we keep giving you good results
so that you keep spending
time on our platform
so that we can keep showing you ads,
and so that you can go
buy products, right?
More strikingly, and I mean, you know,
I guess less strikingly
and more strikingly at the same time,
so facial recognition has been, you know,
very important in this whole
fight against algorithmic bias
and there are interesting
and important work
of Joy Buolamwini and Timnit Gebru
showed that off-the-shelf classifiers
manufactured by some of the most standard
and well-trusted companies such as IBM
showed remarkable
differences in the ability
to classify people based on
their protected attributes,
such as race and gender.
And since I talked about
showing advertisements,
you know, showing advertisement
is in the core business
of many of these platforms.
And there also, there were biases.
I mean, it's not surprising,
but it was observed
that women get shown ads
for low-paying jobs while
men get shown more ads
for high-paying jobs.
Okay, so, you know, as somebody
who might have not seen this before,
or who's skeptic say,
"Okay, you know, this
is what is being shown.
What is the problem with this?
You know, anybody can show
whatever they want to you.
So what is the issue?"
The issue is that the output
of the same algorithms
can alter human perceptions.
Okay, so it's not like just
seeing has no impact on us.
Seeing is believing in this case.
And the same studies,
which found these biases
also found that people
who may or may not have an
opinion about gender bias
or gender and CEO's
after being shown images,
which are distorted or
representation which are distorted,
have distorted perceptions
of what it means to be a CEO.
And I guess we have all
gone through this phase
and no matter which country you live in,
where we are seeing increasing distortion
or increasing divergence
without saying what is
right, what is wrong,
our worldviews are
diverging or polarizing.
So polarization has had a
disruptive effect on democracy.
It has given people
the ability to manipulate
elections and so on.
So there is a lot of
stuff read about here,
and these are the core issues
that I'm going to address in this talk.
But even before I go there,
I want to first address
the question of anatomy,
how does bias emerge?
And to understand that,
we have to understand a
little bit in more detail
what I showed in my first
slide, how do we learn?
You know, what is going
on in this algorithms?
So this is not a mathematical talk.
So unfortunately I will
not be able to show you
a lot of equations, in
other venues I would.
But hopefully I will give
you some concrete idea,
more concrete than in the first slide
so that, you know, you go
back with a very graphic sense
of how these algorithms operate.
So the starting point is
the real world, right?
So this is the world in which we live in.
And when we talk about data,
data doesn't live in the real world,
data is collected from the real world.
And to collect data, you
first need to figure out
how to represent data.
So I'm a person.
If some organization, let's
say the U.S. government
wants to collect data from me,
they will specify that we need
your first name, last name,
age, this, you know, social, whatever.
They'll give me a template
and in most situations
I really do not have an option.
So I need to fill out all
this data and give it to them.
So two points here; one is representation,
which is that in most cases,
I would be given some kind of a form.
It could be electronic, it
could be a physical form
where I fill out information.
It could be somebody
taking pictures, right?
So I need to add a picture,
which is also very specifically
specified in certain cases.
And then certain individuals are selected
for such data collection.
So if you are doing that survey
or trying to estimate
something about a population
is infeasible to collect
data from everybody.
So you will select some sub sample.
Now, to what extent the sample
is good is often not clear.
So data has these two major components.
There are other bells and whistles,
but in the first order
understanding of things,
this is what it is.
Now that you have a collection of data,
you want to learn from this data.
And learning happens
in a hypothesis class.
So the more complex the hypothesis class,
the more you have the ability to learn.
And most learning algorithms
will fix the hypothesis class.
I mean these hypotheses are parameterized.
I mean, it will not be the case
that one hypothesis will explain the data.
So there may be many, many hypothesis,
which explain the data.
So then comes the question
of which one to choose.
So which is the best hypothesis
that will explain the data?
So we have to fix a
mathematical notion of accuracy
or something which helps us select
from this wide class of hypothesis
the one which is the best.
Once you have made these choices,
we go on to find the most accurate model,
and I'm using something
called the training algorithm.
And that gives rise to the
decision-making algorithm,
which then is used in the real world.
So maybe this algorithm
will be used to decide
who to give loan or who not to give loan.
And that has a direct social impact.
Wherever gets loan, their life changes
and whoever doesn't get loan,
their life probably worsens.
I mean, given the fact that
they're looking for loan.
So this creates this feedback loop.
I mean, output of these algorithms
could also feed into other algorithms
and so on and so forth.
So the design choices are human choices.
They are driven by human motivations.
So each step of this process,
there are humans who are deciding,
and their decisions are motivated
by what they think is valuable.
So the real question is,
you know, who decides?
Who does this benefit and who is harmed?
And all of these questions
are very important.
I mean, these questions
are generally not asked
in the design of algorithms,
because whoever is
designing the algorithm,
it's their benefits that
certainly are incorporated
very, very rarely there a discussion
on who could be potentially harmed
and what can we do to
mitigate those harms.
So in all of this algorithms
end up being brittle
and gain the ability
to encode human biases.
Well, one more point I
wanted to make is that,
you know, one of the
reasons why this study
on algorithmic bias really
caught the attention of media
I mean, that's really where it got into
is because in the end, what does it show?
It shows and it gives definitive proof
that humans are biased.
If I catch somebody and
say, "Hey, you're biased,"
they may argue and wriggle
out their, you know, way
through that discussion.
And in the end nothing
conclusive came out.
But if the same person
hands me an algorithm,
which I can keep
repeating again and again,
I mean, keep running it again and again
without any further intervention,
once the algorithm is there, that's it.
And then you can see,
look, I mean, if you're not biased
and how can this algorithm be biased?
So it gives us a definitive proof.
Now without pointing fingers,
it gives us a definite proof
that humans are extremely biased,
and that's what these
algorithms are picking up.
So it gave us a lens
into our own existence.
And it should not be
surprising that whilst studying
or as a bigger goal of
studying algorithm bias
is to try to understand various ways
in which humans can be biased
and design frameworks and
policies to mitigate those biases,
and I'll come to that
towards the end of the talk.
So just a little bit more
graphic image of what goes on.
If I take a simple example,
let's say of who to give loan or not,
let's say the society
consists of, you know,
this is a very toy
caricaturization of the problem,
this is not how it works,
but it'll give you a mathematical
sense of what goes on.
So some people let's say are
women, and some people are men.
I understand that things are not binary,
but for this thing,
let's just consider that.
And traditionally,
there has been disparity
because of the construction
of various social and political systems,
men and women in our society
are not equal, unfortunately.
And suppose we choose features
corresponding to women,
so suppose I pick two features,
features, meaning what
about the individual
do I need to decide whether
to give someone a loan or not?
So let's say as a bank manager I decide,
I'm going to ask to encode
to the extent to which
the person is educated
and the income.
So let's say these are the two
coordinates here that you see
two numbers associated to each person.
Some mathematical encoding
of their highest educational
degree in this case it's five
and some mathematical
encoding in this case it's 10.
This could be 10,000,
this could be 10 million,
but yeah, without assigning units to it,
I just think of the abstract.
And then many of these
algorithms also need
some kind of, you know, historic data.
So in the historic data, I
would probably also need to know
whether this kind of a person
ended up repaying their loan or not.
This information is useful for me,
but I don't want to give loans
to people who are not
going to pay it back to me.
And then, you know, I
talked a lot about models.
So models could be as
simple as selecting lines,
straight lines to divide
the data into positive
and negative examples.
So plus means positive examples
and minus means negative examples,
or it could be something more.
It could be something very complicated.
For example, you could
choose very complex curves
in high dimensions,
which can kind of cherry
pick the points, if you like.
So this is the traditional
machine learning algorithm,
and, I mean, these kinds of
images are more associated
to deep learning algorithms
where there are many parameters,
very high degree polynomials,
and they can really
learn arbitrary concepts.
So then the nice thing
about those learning models
is that they are universal
in the sense that they
can learn any function.
So in all of these choices,
and this is just a subset of the choices,
there can be issues.
We already talked about
societal and historic biases.
What may happen?
You may say, "Oh, I'm not
using gender of a person.
So what's the problem?
I mean, these numbers are fair."
No, these numbers may not be fair
because, you know, as I said,
traditionally, women might
have lesser education,
lesser income.
So these numbers might be
tilted against them, right?
And same about this, right?
I mean, the labels and other,
there can be many inaccuracies,
there can be misrepresentations
in your dataset.
You might have more men than women,
so you don't learn much
about women and so on.
And models of course can
further exacerbate bias
in a very mathematical sense
that I'm going to omit.
But all of these things can
very concretely lead to issues.
But you can see that, you know,
these choices that we're making,
we are making these choices as humans.
Yes, in the end we design an algorithm,
which is a precise object,
but these are the choices we're making.
Let me give you another example of bias,
which is something other
than gender or race,
which we talk a lot about,
something, which I mentioned earlier
in terms of polarization.
And this is bias in a different space,
it's in the space of opinions, okay.
So imagine that this is you
and this is your Twitter or Facebook feed.
So, you know, let's say you log in now,
and between the last time
you logged in and now,
many, many of the people who
you follow or your friends
would have generated posts, okay.
So this is the set of all
posts that Facebook or Twitter
can potentially show to you.
And this is the key thing,
this is their billion dollar algorithm,
the content selection algorithm,
which from this viewed huge,
huge set for each individual
creates a personalized feed.
And I have chosen to represent,
again, as a toy example,
where the set of all documents
or set of all news articles,
or set of all tweets are
divided into two types;
the red type and the blue type, okay.
The situation on the ground
is more complex, of course,
but let's say this is the case.
And this content selection
algorithm also gives you
a very limited ability
to interact with your personalized feed.
So you can say, I like
it, or I don't like it.
I mean, for a very long
time this is what it was.
And now you can do
perhaps a little bit more.
So the reason why this
information was kept so simple
is because when the signal reaching
the content selection
algorithm was very clear.
And so it could use this
next time when you come
to show you a personalized feed again.
So what is really happening?
So what is really happening
in this content selection
algorithm is that
for each individual user,
it represents each
individual user as a point
in some very high dimensional
space of opinions or articles.
So there is this very
high dimensional space
consisting of all possible articles
classified into red and blue.
And in the beginning, the
algorithm has no opinion of you,
no prior of you, so you start
off somewhere in the middle.
So when you start off,
your feed will look kind of balanced.
But then you click on something.
So when you click on something,
the algorithms thinks,
okay, this person seems to like this post
and the post is red.
So let me change it's representation
a little bit towards red.
And this is a very precise movement
that happens in this space.
I mean, these dynamics
are governed by, you know,
the profit function.
So, you know, what is the goal ultimately?
The goal is that the
content selection algorithm
should show you feeds,
which you will keep clicking on, right?
And so that you don't go away.
So they do that.
So maybe now a new feed is generated,
and maybe now you click on a blue one.
And so now you move a little
bit to the blue and so on.
So over a period of time,
in a relatively short period of time,
what we see happening is that two people
starting from very close in the center
their opinions can diverge.
And you know, what that
really means is that,
from the algorithms point of view,
you move into the deep
blue or deep red space.
And after that, your feeds
are basically going to be
just mostly blue or mostly red.
I mean, take all this with
a pinch of salt, okay.
So this is caricaturization
of what is really happening,
but it's pretty close
to what is happening.
So what can we do?
You know, these kinds
of biases are emerging.
So what can we do?
So we can focus on correcting data.
We can talk about
participatory design of models,
you know, so we have to take into account
not only Facebook or Twitter's preferences
or Google's preferences,
but also preferences of the individuals,
which has not been happening so far.
Once we agree on the joint
goals or the joint models,
we can try to design algorithms
that are now constrained
to be fair in some sense.
And just like we have a
police and a legal system
and a police system,
which keeps auditing and doing
things to control people,
we have these algorithmic audit units,
or, you know, companies or whatever,
mostly, you know, civic bodies,
which are studying the impact
of algorithms in users.
So there's a little problem though,
that when I talk about fairness or bias,
you know, it's not just one thing, okay.
It's many things possibly, right?
So when I say something is not fair,
it's not clear what it means.
It may be clear to an individual
who has experience in fairness,
but when we talk about
designing algorithms,
we need to be precise, what do we mean?
And what that really means is
writing down a precise metric,
a precise way to measure
unfairness or bias.
And this picture, which is still partial,
kind of probably gives you a sense that
things are very complex,
the landscape of fairness is very complex.
There are many, many different
types of notions of fairness
that you can consider.
But at least 40, which have legal backing
in various contexts.
And in each context, there
are multiple stakeholders,
and you can prove theorems,
let's say that you
cannot design algorithms,
which satisfy multiple
notions of fairness.
So unfortunately you will
have to fix the context.
And in that context, stick to a definition
or notion of fairness, and then say,
"Okay, let's design
algorithms in that framework,
which are fair."
So this is where some of my work,
which I've been doing over
the last few years comes in.
And one of my main
contributions is to specify
a very general framework for users
to encode their fairness constraints.
So we saw that the landscape
of fairness constraints
can be very complex.
And what we did was to kind of figure out
what's the simplest possible way
for us to mathematically encode
these fairness constraints
and then design algorithms,
which are constrained to be fair.
When you add constrains to a system,
so this is an algorithm here,
which is computing some
function from data.
The moment you constrain it,
a natural question arises is that
the previous algorithm
is not going to work.
So who will design this new algorithm
and whether it's even possible
to design an efficient algorithm.
You know, so efficiency
is the keyword here,
because you can write down a function,
which you would like to compute,
but then if it's not
efficiently computable,
it's not going to happen
in the sense that,
you know, the size of data and the scale
at which we are operating
is so huge that the problem
should also come with
some efficient algorithms.
Otherwise, you know,
you will have to pay some
computational price of fairness.
On the other hand, from the
point of view of let's say
a company like Twitter,
if you say constrain
Twitter's feed, right?
So you give some controls
to the user and say,
"The user will control to
the extent of the content
that they want to see,"
then Twitter will object
immediately and say,
"You know, but now we don't know
what the engagement metrics will be,
and that can really wipe
us out of this market.
So if we're not going to agree to it."
So this is what you make
think of as price of fairness.
Fairness is a great goal.
But in this capitalistic society,
who pays the price of fairness,
who will pay the price of fairness?
So these are very non-trivial
and important questions.
And my work has address the whole pipeline
starting from identifying
bias to fixing data,
figuring out the right models,
developing fair algorithms,
and studying impact.
And so not all algorithms,
oops, okay, so maybe I skipped a slide.
Not out all algorithms are equal.
Some algorithms are very high stakes.
I mean, you know, for example,
the algorithm used to schedule
the fleet of Hertz Car Rental
perhaps has less impact,
you know, at a scale
than something like what you
see in Twitter or Facebook,
or something that you
see in Google search,
or classification
algorithms, or, you know,
or other stuff.
So I've worked on some of
the high stakes applications
and come up with interesting solutions.
You can see more about them.
Many of the solutions
actually come with new demos.
Once we design the
algorithm, we code it up,
we create a demo for you to see,
and if you're really curious,
you can go to this website
and play around with it.
So just to wrap back and say, okay,
so what does the picture look like
in this world of personalization?
Conceptually, it looks like the following:
that our framework
constrains the algorithm
to not let people go
beyond a certain point.
I mean, in retrospect
it seems very simple,
but the hard part is in
designing new algorithms,
which respect these constraints.
So that's the main
contribution of this work.
So all of this was
assuming that we know data,
we know that the data is accurate.
Once you start looking
deeper into the system,
one of the key questions or key issues
that we see is that the
data may not be accurate.
So besides historical and societal biases,
there may be other factors,
which actually come into the way of data.
So let me now explain that.
And now we are going
towards understanding bias
in human decision-making from
algorithmic decision-making.
So we'll make a transition
and then I think in the
next 10 to 15 minutes,
I should be able to
wrap up, 10, 12 minutes.
So Priya, are we taking
the questions at the end
or in the middle?
- If you are open to--
- I think this is a good
point to pause for a minute
and see if anybody has questions
about the previous part.
I'm open, yes.
- Okay, I haven't seen anything
up here in the Q&A yet,
but we can encourage them.
The only note that I
have is that, you know,
Christina's pointed out, I
mean there are lots of people
who are interested,
actually would like to
have the links posted.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so I'll keep on going
and, you know, think about questions
and feel free to
interrupt or ask any time.
I mean, I think it's important to hear--
- I actually, if I may, I
wanted to ask a quick question.
So, you know, it's really
sort of remarkably clear
exposition, Nisheeth of how
our sort of inference systems
are biased and how in turn these results
that are recovered from
these and the claims whatever
can change us, right.
So there's the sort of the
power of the algorithms
that while they encode our bias,
they may also hold the key
to mitigating bias, right?
So they're sort of, you know,
epistemically, they serve
as sort of exposers, right?
They're very effective
exposers of human bias.
So one thing I was curious was, you know,
when you talked about
assigning scores, for example,
we were looking at it, right?
So how much of the bias
really comes from the fact
that, you know, mathematical
scores, et cetera,
have an implicit ordering, right?
Like five is better than 10 or whatever.
So what if we replace at the top layer,
I don't know, I had sort
of a lame suggestion,
why not just have colors or, you know,
something that you can, you know,
at a deeper layer map into numbers?
- That's a great question.
So, yes, I mean, I think
that's a very good question
and the answer to this
is not entirely obvious
because as I already
hinted that, you know,
you can design some beautiful systems,
which are supposed to do
what they're supposed to do,
but in the end you will
also need an algorithm
to find the parameters of the model.
- [Priya] Yeah.
- So much of this stuff is constrained
by that aspect of things.
So the reason to go into
this continuous space
of order numbers, you
know, simplify everything,
the real numbers, not even discreet.
I mean, in the world of discreet numbers,
there's still more you can do
than in the world of continuous numbers.
So the thing is that these algorithms,
which optimized are
essentially algorithms,
which work in continuous spaces,
things like gradient
descent, gradient flows.
I mean, these are inspired again
from physics in some sense.
And yeah, I mean, this is
the set we are working with.
So, you know, if you face a problem today
and let's say you are an engineer
who's working in a company
and whose manager gives the
task to design something,
you're not in a position
to reinvent an algorithm.
- [Priya] Right.
- So you will just use
off-the-shelf algorithm
and you know, you'll just
do the minimum thing.
You say, "Okay, let's
just encode everything
as a real number and ordered in some sense
without putting so much thought
into what impact your decisions have
on the lives of others."
And this also has to do
with a complete failure
of the education system
in some sense, right?
I mean, I must say that
I take responsibility
because, you know, we teach
people design of algorithms,
data structures, and so on,
but you know, a decade ago
nobody in their lecture would even mention
the potential possibility of the impact
that the choices will have.
And now I teach a course
in which I make people
at least be more aware of the assumptions
and their potential impacts.
We still do the same thing,
but we just make more aware of the impact.
- Just changing around the
categories of representation
is not enough A, because
there are too many algorithms
lying around, people will just use them.
You have to completely start
with a new set of categories,
but I guess the ultimate
limit, as you said, you know,
is that we have a well-defined
mathematical space
in which we live.
- Right.
I mean, but it's also a
very challenging question.
I mean, you know, how
do you capture a human?
I mean, all said and done,
I mean, if you want to implement this
on some kind of computer, then
going back to Turing's work.
I mean, Turing proved that any computer
is equivalent to the doing machine, right?
So at some level you will have to encode
something as complex as human
in let's say a binary form
or I mean, some representation, right?
So there is a lot to say
here and a lot to do here.
So by no means I'm pretending
that we have solved any problem.
In fact, in this part of my talk,
I'm gonna tell you how we
did not solve that problem
that we aim to solve actually.
And the reason, if I may continue, Priya,
- Yeah, please go ahead, yeah, yeah.
- Is that so far, I assume that data.
So all of these algorithms
that we designed work
as long as the data is accurate.
So forget the issue that, you know,
women might have historically
lower salary than men,
but we do assume that the salary
is what it is being reported.
I mean, you know, that
the person is reporting
the right salary, right?
Or we are measuring information correctly,
but as we delve more into
human-generated data,
it becomes even more clear
that the data that we
record is first of all,
not necessarily close to the
data that we should report,
even if you want to record
somebody that ethnicity, right,
it's not clear that when we look at it,
when we record and we do
have that person set history.
I mean, it's like as a physicist,
you can understand this probably.
I mean, you wish you had the true data,
but you know, data traveling
over billions of years
coming from very far,
and then add some noise,
and, you know, all kinds of
things might happen to that.
So in this context,
what we have been seeing is
due to a variety of reasons.
For instance, you know, often
we need ethnic information,
but we don't have ethnic information
because it may be illegal
to have ethnic information
to record.
So what do we do?
We impute ethnic information
from other things.
So that gives rise to a noisy estimate
of somebody's ethnic information, okay.
Maybe because of privacy concerns,
you might have to add noise to data.
And what I wanted to focus
on in this rest of the talk
in this little 10 minutes
is implicit biases.
So much of this data also comes from
applying certain evaluation
processes on individuals.
So for instance, SAT scores.
I mean, we here at Yale
are in the business
of taking decisions
about students, faculty,
everybody all the time.
You know, we want to recruit individuals
for some vaguely specified goals,
but we choose metrics
that's SAT score-based
that and the other,
there is a whole evaluation process.
And these evaluation processes
can have implicit biases.
And the punchline is
that much of the stuff
that I talked about this first generation
study of algorithmic bias
actually does not seem to work well
when data is perturbed.
And Alexander Madre,
who is an expert in designing algorithms
for perturb data hopefully
we'll tell you more
about this on Monday.
So let me just talk about
one type of perturbation,
which is implicit biases.
And this was the punchline.
you know, even if your intention
was to correct for fairness,
if it failed to take into
account the precise way
in which that data can be perturbed,
you know, the cure can
be worse than the cause.
Is that the right saying?
I think so.
No, the effect could
be the worst than cure
or something like that, yeah.
Sorry, I'm getting a bit tired.
So implicit bias is
rampant in the real world.
There is lots of evidence.
I'm not qualified to do these experiments,
but there are very prominent
economists and sociologists
who do this.
And in almost all aspects
of our social interactions,
we see rampant implicit bias
to just give an example,
which is relevant to us.
I think there were studies done
where emails were sent
to Ivy League professors.
The content of the email
was exactly the same
except in some emails,
the names name was changed
from a male to a female,
to a white sounding name,
a black sounding name.
And there was significant differences
in the percentages of responses.
Now, one can always argue
and try to explain each
individual data point.
But when there are so many people
who study this and find systematic issues,
one cannot deny that there is
something called implicit bias
in this world, which is really
the unconscious attribution
of qualities or lack there off
of members of particular groups.
So the bottom line is
that what you observe,
the data that you observe
may not be accurate.
So let's look at a very simple problem,
which now starts moving from a problem,
which you may not associate
necessarily to computer science,
but nevertheless is still
an algorithmic problem.
And many of us here
might have actually tried
to solve this problem.
So the problem is very simple.
Again, it's a toy problem.
Don't take any of this
stuff too seriously,
the goal is to explain the point.
Suppose you have M individuals,
let's say hundred individuals.
In this case, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight individuals,
and each individual has
some latent utility.
So this is the true
utility of an individual,
whatever it is.
And I have four interview spots, okay.
So I have maybe one faculty
spot in my department,
but I want to short list
four people to interview.
So what shall I do?
You know, as Priya said,
one of the reasons why we're
including them as numbers
is that we can compare.
So the higher the number the better it is.
So our goal is to shortlist
these four people or n people,
which maximize the
cumulative latent utility.
So this has a very simple
algorithm actually,
which I think everybody here,
you don't need to take an algorithms class
to design such an algorithm,
which is to first find
the one with the maximum,
remove them from the
set, find the next one,
set, find the third one,
remove them from the
set, find the fourth one.
That's your set of four people
that you would like to interview, okay.
This is very simple,
even a child can solve this problem.
The issue with this is that it assumes
that these blue numbers here that you see,
which are the true
utilities are the real ones
that we're seeing, okay.
But in reality, if we are
suffering from implicit bias,
we might not see this two
utility or latent utility.
So here's a very simple
mathematical model of implicit bias,
which is suppose there
is some parameter, beta,
you can think of beta, let's
say 0.9 or in this case half.
And for every person in a certain group,
you view their utility to you.
The observed utility to yourself
is half of the true utility.
Of course, you don't know that.
You're not doing this
process, you know, explicitly.
So this is my view.
So I'm let's say the person
who can observe the entire thing.
So I mean, you know, as an individual
who's making this call,
you're not aware of this beta.
If you were, then you would
correct it, but you're not.
So you just view this person
as being useful to you
to the extent of five units
as opposed to 10 units.
So now what would you do?
I mean, what would you do?
You would use the same algorithm again,
but with the perturbed dataset, right?
So instead of the true utility
of this person being 18,
now it's nine.
So now when you go and
select the top four,
instead of selecting the top four,
which maximize your latent utility,
you maximize the observed utility.
And these are not the
same numbers anymore.
So this is a strange situation
because it's actually good for everybody
if you can see the truth,
because you just don't know
that this person actually
has higher utility for you,
because of your biases.
Your biases are stopping
you from doing this.
So what can we do?
One can do anti-bias training.
I mean, this is the traditional
solution that you can apply.
It has limited efficacy.
There's actually a very
interesting solution
to aversion of this problem,
which is called the Rooney rule,
which has been used
in the context of the
National Football League here.
So the Rooney rule roughly says that
in the process of
selecting who to interview
for head coach of an NFL team,
you must interview at
least one black person,
if I get it correctly.
And there is evidence,
at least in the media,
that this seems to be
a useful thing to do.
So the question is, is it
really in this simple problem,
does it really work, and
if so, to what extent?
So what we did recently is
to look at the following
intervention algorithm.
So now we say, okay, so
there's a new parameter
that we introduced L, and we
say, select at least L people
from this disadvantaged group.
So even though you don't
know your implicit biases,
I can still constrain
you, as a policymaker,
to say that you must select
at least let's say two people
from this set of women to interview.
And what we can show is that,
you know, you can pick
a value of L carefully.
Then once I've fixed
this as a policymaker,
then you're still doing
whatever you're doing
with an implicit biases
can recover the right set.
So this might sound a
bit counter-intuitive,
but there is a nice mathematical
explanation for this.
So we can come up with interesting
algorithmic interventions
in these situations.
One can also ask, you know,
"Okay, so it seems to
solve the problem locally,
what about the long-term impact?"
So we can model this process
of the dynamical system
and also do experiments with people.
And we can show that, you know,
under a simple and well established rule
of how humans change their opinions,
you know, which is modeled
to Bayesian learning,
the Rooney rule over time,
significantly impacts the implicit bias.
So we come up with a new
way, at least, you know.
We come up with a new way as a suggestion
to do this kind of training
against implicit bias.
Anyway, so if you're interested,
you can look at some of
our work on this stuff.
I'm just going to end now,
because I think I'm out of time.
So what did we see in this talk?
So one of the first things is that,
you know, human decisions
can appear in this objective
or seemingly objective world of algorithms
and make them biased.
Bias can mean very different things
in very different contexts.
And sometimes it may be impossible
to satisfy all the constraints of bias
in algorithmic situations and
also real world situations.
And there's a great demand
to design algorithms,
given the rampantness of these algorithms
and the impact they
have already on society.
There's a great movement going on,
at least in certain communities,
which is thinking about redesigning
some of these high stakes algorithms
to keep in mind the context
and the stakeholders.
And finally, an understanding
of algorithmic bias
cannot only inform the design of fair
or unbias artificial algorithms,
but if you view policy
decisions as also algorithms
acting on populations,
then it also gives us insights
into how to redesign policies.
And some of our work is
heading in that direction.
You can see more of my
work on this website,
Controlling Bias.
And Priya already mentioned, you know,
this is not an MBA where
we reach only technical
or mathematical problems can
lead you to good solutions.
So here at Yale, we have a
collective, I like to think of,
we call this Computation
and Society Initiative,
a bunch of like-minded
people who come together
to try to understand how we
can address these problems
from a multidisciplinary point of view.
And I would stop here and
thank you for your attention,
and Priya, it all over to you.
- Yep, thank you so much, Nisheeth.
This was absolutely wonderful.
What a clear exposition.
I think as always, you know,
every conversation with you,
I learn new things.
And I think what you have
clearly showed us is, you know,
epistemically, algorithms serve
as very effective exposers
of bias, and that we can
also in turn use them
as devices to mitigate the bias in turn.
So they are sort of very, very powerful
and useful at the same time.
So I think we have one question in the Q&A
that I will read out,
and then I of course
have a couple of my own,
but I will hold my
horses for a little bit.
So our first question is from
one of our regular attendees,
Jenny.
Hi, Jenny.
And her question is instead of
constraining the maximum bias
a user can arrive at, could
you also imagine other ways
to push the user away from their biases?
For example, showing other random contents
or even the opposite of
what they liked before.
This could also stimulate new interests.
well, I guess she's referring possibly
to the polarization example.
- Right, right.
So I think I understand the question.
Thank you, Priya for reading it
and thank you, Jenny for
asking this question.
I think in the picture,
it's not the person that
we are constraining.
It's the representation of the person
that we are constraining,
and it's actually exactly
doing what you're suggesting
in some sense.
So the constraint is on the information
that we are going to show this person.
So in the most simple sense,
what it translates to is that let's say,
you know, Twitter cannot show you
completely polarized content,
it has to show you at least let's say 20%.
Now this 20% is an arbitrary number,
but let's say 20% content,
which may differ from your
current political view.
And then the question arises,
how do you choose this content?
Now, the real, you know,
so we all know through personal experience
that if you meet a random person
with a diametrically
opposite political opinion,
it's unlikely they will have any impact
on your political opinion.
So we want to pick articles,
which are the most likely
to have an impact on you.
So, I mean, in some sense to explain it
in colloquial language,
I mean, if your friend
or your family tried to
explain something to you,
you might be more swayed
as opposed to a person who
you don't like a priory,
or who you don't trust or
who you don't know a priory,
right?
So that the task of
selecting the right articles
or the right news content
is a very important one.
And that's really where the
fine optimization goes in.
- So yeah, that's what we do actually.
- Great, thank you.
Okay, so I guess I have this
other question actually,
which was about the Rooney rule.
So, you know, I'm going to stray
and use my own experience
as a guide, right?
So isn't it true,
and I think, you know, this
is echoed more generally,
isn't it true that when
you have one representative
of a disadvantaged
group amongst, you know,
in that interview example that you had
that then they come to stand
for everything that that group represents;
positive and negative?
So that one person could much
more easily serve as a trigger
to our biases.
But if you have two,
then there's a little more noise, right?
So, you know, you can--
- And that's hundred percent correct
and that's really what our results shows.
So the parameter L that I
talked about is not one.
So, yeah, so that's right.
So I think the question that was raised
in the literature was, well, you know,
what can you show about this Rooney rule?
And so we cannot show much
about the L equal to one case,
but we can show, at least mathematically,
we can show, you know,
that if L is something a
little bit larger than one,
then it has, yeah,
so I think intuition is
a hundred percent right,
that the noise kind of cancels out, right?
And then you start getting
the signal of the quality,
because from one sample, you know,
you might get something
which is pretty far off
from, you know, the
true mean, for instance.
But if you have many samples,
then you get a better idea of the group.
So thank you for asking this question.
Unfortunately, we already solved this
and I can tell you more about it.
- Glad to hear that.
- Yeah, but you're right
on track on this one, yes.
- L had to be greater than one.
- It means you completely
understood what I said,
which is very flattering.
- So I think there's
a question from Talia.
And the question is you described
the context specific nature
of bias and fairness.
What are the implications
of that context dependence
for efforts to develop more general AI?
Are there ways to reduce bias
in the application of
relatively general AI tools?
It's a great question, yeah.
- Yeah, so this is a very good question,
but a very hard question as well.
I mean, if I were to give a
talk on AI and machine learning,
I think I would first start
by kind of bringing it down
to the level of actually is
than what the media portrays it is.
So we are nowhere close
to the kind of stuff.
I mean, you know, there
have been successes.
So I'm not worried about
right now generally.
But in a very specific context,
let's say you design an algorithm,
which potentially can be
used in multiple contexts.
Then there has to be a component there,
which somehow quickly
recognizes or learns the context
and then specializes itself
to a well-agreed-upon notion
of fairness in that context.
Now, it cannot just arbitrarily choose.
But I mean, you know,
so the architects of the algorithm, right,
have to agree a priory,
you know, for what context,
what notion of fairness
or bias is important.
And so that information has to be included
as a part of the algorithm itself.
I don't know if it answers your question,
but we are very far from
constructing any such thing.
But yeah, these are the big,
big questions, the frontiers.
Hopefully in the next few years,
we will get to some of these.
- So please go ahead and
share and type your questions.
So Nisheeth, while we are
waiting for someone else,
I'm gonna pipe in again.
So, you know, in physics
we have this intuition
that when the central limit
theorem operates, right?
So when you marginalize over
many, many, many observations,
you kind of get rid of the noise.
I mean, would I be right in saying that
that isn't quite true
in the kind of problems?
- So that's a very precise
mathematical theorem.
I mean, thank you for
asking that question.
So what does the central
limit theorem say?
It says the following: suppose
you have random variables,
X1 to Xn, right?
And you take the average or take the sum
and divide them by square root n.
Square root n is the variance, right?
Let's say these are
Gaussian, I mean, whatever.
These are random variables with mean zero.
- They are not correlated with each other.
- Yeah, not correlated,
but the important point is that you took n
and the function that
you computed of them,
which is the sum,
or rather, let's say sum
divided by some number.
No particular random variable
has a very high 'influence'
on this function.
So the reason why physics
works is that nature
I mean, very rarely we'll have functions
where it is a function of
many, many variables, right?
But somehow a very small set of variables
dictate the outcome of the function.
But you know, the kind of
algorithms we are talking about
in this, we are not just doing
a simple statistics calculation.
We are optimizing, we are
picking the maximum among,
let's say a set of K people, or K scores,
or something very brittle,
I would say, you know.
So there's a brittleness
that comes into it.
And I think this is a perfect question
for our next conversation on Monday,
because I mean, the
brittleness of these algorithms
is what Alexander Madre studies
without worrying so much about bias,
but you know, about the brittleness.
And one of the ways in
which you can kind of
include your intuition from physics
in the design of these algorithms
is to smoothen these functions out.
- Exactly.
I was gonna say you smoothen.
- You smoothen these functions out.
So what are ways to
smoothen functions out?
I mean, in mathematics,
there are many ways.
I mean, there are these operators,
you can take a function
and you want to compute
its value at one point.
Well, you can take a small
neighborhood around you
and just take the average
around this point.
So, you know, you can
do a short random walk
or Brownian emotion around this, you know,
and then take the
expectation of the function.
So there are various tricks
in which you can smoothen
the function out.
And smoothening helps carry
through your intuition.
But what is not clear
is that this smoothening
will not very dramatically
impact the accuracy.
- Yup.
- So when you talk about, you know,
we're talking about trillion
dollar economies, okay,
This is not a joke.
A second decimal place in drop in accuracy
of something means many,
many, many more dollars
than I have or I will ever see, okay.
- Yeah, huge consequences,
huge consequences.
- Right, huge consequences.
So convincing a company
such as Facebook or Google
or whatever to move towards algorithms
which are less brittle is
currently an impossible task.
- [Priya] Right.
- You know, and the only way to do that
is to first formulate a regulation.
I mean, you know, without any regulation
which ties their hand
somehow, you cannot...
I mean, this is really
the context of this talk.
What is the purpose of this talk?
The purpose of this talk is, you know,
to give influential people
who may not be experts
in algorithms, but who have the influence
in various domains, right?
Go and have a conversation
about algorithmic bias
and the impact, and then, you know,
eventually gained the ability
at the highest levels of
decision-making in this country
and others to have the right conversation
with these tech companies,
to hold and twist their arms and say,
"No, you have to do this."
Because if you go and say, "No, do this,"
when you know it not possible to do.
- Yeah, no, right.
- But yeah, designing smooth algorithms
is what will solve many
problems, actually,
not just this problem.
- To be continued on Monday.
Thank you so much, Nisheeth.
- Okay.
- So first of all, there's a
question from Sean Barrett.
Sean is on the faculty in
the Physics Department.
Very interesting talk, thank you.
It's interesting that the Rooney rule
with L greater than one
is seen as something
that could be effective theoretically.
In the sports media, recent
coverage has suggested
that the Rooney rule has not been working
since the numbers in 2020
are essentially the same
as they were in 2003.
I think they might be using L equals one.
But another issue is
that the size of the pool
of all NFL coaches is not that big.
What L value, L equals two perhaps,
made a difference in your own model?
Thank you.
- So, excellent question, Sean.
So I don't know much
about NFL, I must say.
So I would probably not be
able to address your question
about NFL and why the Rooney
rule isn't working anymore.
It seemed like at some point,
when I looked at news articles,
they seem to suggest
that it has some impact,
and it also was being
used in other settings,
corporate hiring and so on.
But I think for reasons that
were mentioned by Priya,
okay, so first of all, our results hold
under some assumptions,
and those assumptions are that
people's true utilities are distributed
according to some random variables.
And that has a role to
play in our analysis.
So if that assumption is not
true, our result doesn't apply.
First of all, let me
just say this upfront.
So maybe then that would suggest is that
the samples that we are choosing
do not satisfy the assumptions
that are required by our model,
because our model does
predict that will work,
that's a possibility.
And Sean, I will be happy to
have any conversation with you
(Nisheeth speaking faintly)
- Thanks, Nisheeth.
I see Richard and Barbara,
and I see them waving to say, hello.
Yeah, hi.
We can't hear you.
Yeah, they're still muted.
- There we are, I think.
- There we are.
- Yeah, lovely to see you both.
- We enjoyed it very much, yeah.
- Yeah, very, very interesting talk.
Barbara, any questions?
Do you have any questions for Nisheeth?
Richard.
- No, we don't, thank you.
- Okay, great.
Are there any other questions, Ty?
Do you see anybody else?
- [Ty] I don't see any others.
Thank you, I think we picked them all up.
- Okay, great.
So thank you, Nisheeth
for this wonderful talk
and for taking the time to
come and speak to us today.
And we look forward to
the conversation on Monday
to further explore these
very sort of profound truths
that you have helped us
understand about algorithms;
what they can do, and
what they ought to do,
and what they ought to do better
than they're currently doing.
So I want to wish everyone a
very good Thanksgiving break
and a nice Thanksgiving celebration
for those of you who are fortunate enough
to have a family celebrations
and are able to travel and so on.
So I just wanted to mention
that our upcoming talk,
the next talk in this series
is going to be by Kyle Cranmer
in the Inference series.
He's a physicist, particle physicist,
and he'll be addressing the
issue of how do we look at
very large number of events
at the Collider like CERN
and try to infer laws,
make discoveries and so on.
And before that talk, we
also have, in addition,
one of our distinguished book series talks
and Mapping as Knowing series talk
by a neuroscientist, Mariano Sigman
and the Mapping as Knowing series talk.
This is mapping the brain
and that is on December 8.
So at this point, I just
want to thank everyone,
in particular, Ty.
thank you so much, Ty for, as always,
helping make these events happen
and to Guy for helping with the AV,
and to all of you for attending,
and last but not least to
Nisheeth for speaking to us.
Thank you very much and good evening.
Yeah, bye.
- Thank you so much.
- [Ty] Priya, let me just
mention, the postdoc conversation
will be taking place at
five o'clock on Monday,
a bit of a departure from
our usual time of three.
So it'll be a 5:00 PM.
Our regular attendees might
wanna take note of that.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Ty
for that announcement.
Okay, bye.